all right Mike is with us hey Mike in
Oshkosh Wisconsin how are you I've been
better been worse okay how can I help
see I ran into a little bit of a
financial problem I was working out of
state for over a year and a half and I
came back I just owned for two weeks
come back for two days blah blah and I
found out through my aunt she called my
name was in the paper my house was going
through a foreclosure we'll come to find
out my wife wasn't making house payments
and I was trying to work with Wells
Fargo they were impossible for to work
with for a loan modification and I wound
up selling some I was going to take some
money out of my 401k they get caught up
it was twenty-two thousand dollars
behind well I found out through by 401k
that I had a zero balance and my wife
and I taken everything out of my 401k I
was home one day early from work I got
the mail you know I trusted her through
all this whole time and I got the mail
and I thought she was paying the polite
this was during the wintertime when I
got the mail and third power life it was
$3,000 she wasn't paying that I was laid
office last year I get no answers from
her first she's paying bills paying
bills or whatever and we've been married
18 years I was laid off for three months
it's last winter got back to work and
that guy I called into the office for
calling in by unemployment while I was
at work which I wasn't doing and I
called unemployment to see what the last
transaction was made while it's still
ongoing so she was between the both of
us working and her calling in my
unemployment as $1,000 a week or better
and you know I try and figure out where
this thousand dollars a week is going we
had no money and she just clams up I
told her I got into a pretty good heated
discussion with her trying to figure out
what the heck is going on and I bought
up getting hauled away I didn't go to
jail I just said we'll see it's someone
else's hostage so pretty upset I didn't
do anything physical or anything like
that but
I get no answers from her I told her to
get out of the hall she said she's not
going anywhere as I you know everything
she's not a gambler or a drug addict
okay I don't I have no idea you know I'm
about to give up I don't want to but you
know she's pulled so many strings I you
know I sold sold my land and paid off my
house my house is paid off right now
it's uh an older farm house I sold 34
acres and kept six who paid my house off
but I just can't seem to get back on my
feet and I'm up for suggestions that's
about it in a nutshell um well there's a
lot of stuff going on here yeah and I
can't I can't tell what it is in this
discussion completely I'll tell you a
couple of observations I have what would
I do if I were in your shoes is my way I
always try to answer the questions if I
woke up in this the first thing I want
you to you got to figure out what the
future looks like and what the steps are
for that future to happen
and and part of that future then is you
have to figure out what part of this is
your fault because that's the only part
you can you can control so I think you
guys need to sit down with a good
marriage counselor if you have any
chance of putting this marriage together
keeping this marriage together and you
obviously have a horrendous horrible
methodology for handling money both of
you suck is that fair uh see I wasn't
really handling the money I thought I
know you abandoned your wife and then
you gripe about what she's done with the
money I think she's really screwed up
too by the way so I'm not taking up for
her but you got to own your part of this
you jerk you drove off into the sunset
and threw money back at the house and
then griped about the way it was handled
and and and beat you know and just like
it's all her fault it's not her fault
you completely walked off and dumped it
on her so it's your job to carry part of
the decision-making the fact that you
have no idea what's going on in your
household for two years it's completely
unacceptable Mike
on your part now is what she's done
acceptable no crap man there's no
telling what's going on with this woman
I can't tell where all this money's
going either it's crazy land right yeah
so you guys got to sit down and go okay
we gonna start acting like a married
couple here where we actually talk about
life and about the house payment and
since we've had all these problems we're
going to start just kind of doing an
audit every month where both of us are
involved in the decision-making and both
of us are involved in seeing the bills
being paid and nobody's going to apply
for anything like loans or unemployment
or pull money out of 401ks ever again or
this marriage does end yeah
Oh am I wrong for trusting her to take
care of me like I said we've been
married for 18 years and then the last
trusting is one thing you are wrong
you're not wrong for trusting her you
are wrong for abandoning her and asking
her to handle it all by herself without
any help or any input from you and then
you just drove off into the sunset and
assumed it was done you you know you
that's just not right so yeah you left
too much weight on her shoulders and it
snapped now I don't know what snapped
means but uh she's obviously done some
things that are completely unacceptable
the main ones I'm concerned with are the
lying that she's done around this and
because that makes it hard to trust
again
let's pretend she hadn't lied about this
stuff and hadn't done weird stuff like
apply for unemployment knowing that you
weren't unemployed which is kind of
called fraud yeah yeah I old fraud for
fraud Barclay a little stuff like that
yeah I mean it's a mess and you know and
how do you get money out of somebody's
401k without them signing up for it
she signs your dadgum name to it is what
she did that's just straight-up illegal
exactly so that stuff is just crazy land
that's what I'm talking about on her
part but what drove her to do that maybe
she felt like you trusted her and she
couldn't handle it and the bills weren't
getting paid and she knew they had to
get paid some way so she's cleaning them
out and paying the bills and she's
horrible at handling money and so the
money's going out of that place like
water out of a sieve that's what it
sounds like might have happened or
there's a
dark secret or some kind of weirdness
beyond belief is going on with drugs or
alcohol or Affairs or something I don't
know but I don't
doesn't necessarily have to be that so I
if I'm in your shoes is how I answer
this I'm going to say okay I didn't do a
good job of walking with my wife I left
all the weight of this on her and she
snapped now when she snapped did she
screw up and did she do some really dumb
and illegal things yes now does that
mean we want to end the marriage well
we'll get into marriage counseling and
figure that out I guess and if you're
going to end the marriage then you just
go forward from this point forward and
figure out how what your life looks like
because it will be without her but I'm
going to sit down and it with a
counselor with the two of you if I'm you
and say okay I'm going to own the part
of this I left too much weight on you
and I'm sorry for that but man this
stuff you've done here is just it just
causes any man to melt down I've had to
sell off the farm I've had to do all
this other stuff and see now you got
your house paid off but I'm not sure how
long it's gonna stay paid off because
this woman's not above going in under
the current system you use she's not
above going and signing up for a
mortgage with your name on it and then
taking your house back into debt without
you knowing it and then you have to go
in and you're left with the idea of
either prosecuting your own wife for
identity theft or you're left with which
is possible by the way or you're left
with you know back in debt again and the
whole thing screwed up again so the
system the process you all are using has
to cease it has to stop we have to put a
bullet in the in this and these bad
ideas and it starts with good marriage
counseling and it starts with both of
you owning up what's wrong
and her clamming up I can't go forward
with her clamming up she's got to come
out and say where the money went
say what happened and she can do that
the safety of a marriage counselors
office but if she refuses to talk about
it and wants to continue to do the
things the way they're done now then
she's saying she wants this to be over
because the way things are going now no
sane person would stay in this deal if
you think this is the way life is going
to look for the next five years because
you'll never get ahead with the
you guys have got to fix this broken
relationship and this broken process and
if you'll go to marriage counseling I'll
put you in Financial Peace University as
my guest
hold on and Kelly I'll sign you up if
you guys want to go bike
you